the FBI that I see is tens of thousands
of agents and analysts and staff working
their tails off to keep Americans safe
the FBI that I see is people decent
people committed to the highest
principles of integrity and
professionalism and respect that was FBI
director Chris Rea responding to the
president's assertion that his agency is
in quote tatters following all the
bombshell revelations we've been talking
about of anti-trump bias by the bureau's
former top investigator Peter struck and
while that hearing was unfolding Fox
News reported another potential conflict
involving an Obama holdover they coming
out of the woodwork this time at the
Justice Department Bruce or was demoted
and stripped of his title associate
Deputy Attorney General yesterday
morning after the house Intel committee
learned that he met during the 2016
campaign with Christopher Steele the
former British spy who authored the
infamous Russian dossier joining us now
to discuss is Republican congressman
from Florida Matt Gaetz and Democratic
strategist Joel Payne who was deputy
national press secretary and former
Senate Majority Leader Harry Reid's
guide great to see you both Joel let's
start with you there are a lot of people
working for this investigation who are
political adversaries of the President
and if the shoe were on the other foot
and this was an investigation of Hillary
Clinton and the investigation was
stacked with anti Hillary prosecutors
you guys have been going crazy
we have streeter struck in this case who
we've discovered as in sending
anti-trump texts during the debates he
was pretty much at every big interview
what are your thoughts on the status of
the FBI now after seeing this play out
well centering because the shoes
actually been on the other foot before
right if we go back about 23 years to
Ken Starr in his investigation you know
if you do some research you'll see that
actually four of his top five deputies
were all Bush scalia reagan appointee
types I think actually Alex
a czar who was just appointed president
Trump's HHS secretary was fourth in line
to Ken Starr and he was a Scalia local
law clerk so my point is I can't so you
can't invalidate so or you can't
invalidate no no because you cannot
equate I clerked on the court now a
Scalia law clerk by the way Justice
Scalia I knew him well and he hired
liberals conservatives moderates hired
kids from all different backgrounds as
does justice Thomas
there's no litmus test there it's about
merit so you're saying that if someone
clerks on the Supreme Court for a more
conservative judicially conservative
justice that person should be barred
from an investigation what I'm saying is
I wouldn't have a problem with what I'm
saying what I'm saying is that you're
asking if the shoes on the other foot
I'm pointing out Alec's a czar was in no
way or any of these guys who worked on
the Starr hearing they didn't have this
type of internal conflicts where they
were representing the other side that's
a difference in congressman you've been
all over this representing one party the
White House or the Clinton Foundation
and then you hop into work for Mahler
and you're suddenly investigating the
president that's a nice little revolving
door well yeah we've had Hillary
Clinton's own fan club investigating her
meanwhile you've got these people who
bring their anti-trump bias to the
Muller investigation today I asked
Christopher Rea did
Muller have a standard where people had
to agree to hate the president in order
to work for him and Christopher Rea
wouldn't answer that question as to
whether or not there was a litmus test
where people had to bring anti-trump
bias but time and again we see instances
and you know what Laura there's more to
come
we're gonna see time and again other
circumstances you didn't even mention
Andrew Weissman who was praising that we
do yeah absolutely who were who were
actively defying the president States
Jim Jordan posed a question today about
Peters about Peter struck to the
Christopher ray let's watch did Peter
struck helped produce and present the
application to the FISA Court to secure
a warrant to spy on Americans associated
with the Trump campaign congressman I'm
not prepared to discuss anything about
as a process and this what was presented
to the FISA Court I do not believe that
I can legally and appropriately share a
FISA Court submission with this
committee I'm not sure that's correct
it's absolutely false and what the FISA
Court does is still you can still have a
check on that Congress can still check
on what the cough eyes of Court does you
have an obligation to do that and who
submits an application that's not any
type of confidential or classified
information we don't want to live in a
world where the FBI can use the fact
that they've submitted documents to a
court as a shield to oversight we didn't
get an answer as to whether or not the
FBI used taxpayer money to go by this
dossier and Peter struck who hated the
president possibly was the person who
packaged all of this together brought it
to a the FISA Court and launched this
entire false Russia collusion theory in
the first place it's absolutely
ludicrous struck as at the center of all
this and if struck is the person who
prepared this application everything
else is fruit of the poisonous tree my
law school the system is working okay
you want accountability we've got
accountability we've got checks and
balances here you're finding these
things out we have transparency and a
treasure hunt to find out about struck
why didn't it like if I were Muller and
I wanted to really preserve the
integrity of the investigation in the
summer when they relieved him of his
duties I would have come out and said we
found out something disturbing about a
member of our team we decided to
proactively relieve him of his duties
they shipped him over to HR which is
kind of an odd place I wouldn't have put
him there
but nevertheless I would have been very
transparent about it self reported by
Muller these are circumstances where we
have to have outside watchdog groups in
the inspector general come in and expose
this double standard I am happy to be on
the side of Bob mother Bob Muller served
tours of duty in Vietnam has a Purple
Heart has served Otto believe our FBI
director I'm not saying that what I'm
saying is somebody of impeccable
character why we assume that Bob Muller
is operating out of
all right look at who he's hiring so his
kid stars can start hiring going back to
Scalia tires of Muller that are
blatantly anti Trump's able to go back
to all these findings of the Whitewater
investigation because ken starr just
going back to this point because I'm a
lawyer this really bugs me that you're
trying to make a any type of legal
equivalency ken starr's team and I know
those gentlemen very well they happen to
be yes many of them work for the bush
Justice Department they however did not
personally represent people who were
antagonistic politically to a President
Clinton they were not representing one
side and then going to work on the other
that's not that's a common inherent
political affiliation what does it mean
that doesn't mean fair judgment they're
not me
now would you assume why would you
assume that Bob Muller why no why
because we have Bruce or at the Justice
Department who's been relieved of his
duties because it turns out of his duty
as associate Deputy Attorney General
because it turns out he was meeting with
we're moving on to why the integrity of
the Justice Department is being
questioned right now and it's important
this that's why Christopher way was up
on Capitol Hill Bruce or very quickly
well it's ludicrous that Bruce or had
this type of access and brought this
type of bias to bear and look it would
be one thing if you had one person who
expressed their viewpoint but time and
again you continue to see circumstances
or struck Jeannie ray over and over
again people who hate the president
investigating him and by the way the
double standard is evidenced in the fact
that Hillary Clinton was investigated by
our own fan club
well it's good we're out of time so
we'll have you back once a short segment